and welcome back everyone
it is a Burt caste I've been off for a
little while
I apologize I've been busting my ass
part of life is working and and I pay my
bills by being on the road and being on
the road means I can't be around great
comics and can't have amazing
conversations and quite honestly I don't
get to hang out with my wife and that's
why we're talking right now together
we have one microphone it is late at
night we're supposed to go to bed so we
can wake the girls up early and go to
school
we've bought pepper spray and batons man
what did you want to talk about well
Burt I wanted to talk about Harry's
razors
Harry's calm that's H a r ry s dot-com
this new razor blade you've been using
and I have to tell you on the body part
you've been using it on it's pretty
fabulous
Harry's will ship for free razors and
razor blades to your house what you
didn't well I mean everybody knows you
have a beard but not everybody knows
that you still shave and it's not your
chest and it's not your legs is a very
special body part so Harry's calm has
razors and razor blades they're German
made razor blades and Harry starter kit
is just 15 dollars and that includes a
razor three blades and your choice of
Harry's shave cream or foaming gel
whichever you prefer which do you prefer
babe the gel or the cream gel he prefers
the gel as an added bonus you can get
five dollars off your first purchase
with my code bert cast
so after use your code you get an entire
month's worth of Shaving for just $10 so
when you check out just put in the
purchase code bert cast BER TC AST it's
pretty cool I mean I haven't used the
razor myself but the effects of the
razor are super smooth is that good
okay good so check out Harry's razor
Harry's razors Harry's calm calm all the
monies that we make from these
advertisements go exactly it about go
directly to my wife so so please please
please use that coupon code all right
let's do an episode of a podcast it is
my pleasure to sit with a woman that's
very opinionated very interesting very
fascinated and one of the fascinating oh
that one her podcast is called dork
forest and it's all about hanging out
people that are obsessed with things so
she sits with people that are obsessed
with professional wrestling with with I
would say fishing like anything that
you're obsessed with she'd be a she's
interested in listening to yeah so she
is a very fascinated person and very
fascinating she's been a stand-up comic
since 1986 a massive respect to an OG in
the game by the way that's the first
time she's ever been referred to as an
OG in the game Original Gangster yep no
no oh gee oh gee I don't even know if
anyone can hear you
alright ladies and gentlemen the PERT
cast is back we're hammering them out
for the next five weeks because I'm
doing one every single day this week and
our beliefs in two week because I'm
gonna start doing a guest on Tuesday and
a personal solo one on Thursday or
Friday so yeah that's right bill burr is
inspiring he inspires everybody so
today's guest without further ado
gee in the comedy game straight out of
Milwaukee Jackie Kashian
grab a seat over there Priscilla are you
really gonna be in this the whole time
Doug Benson told me he's like next time
you do a podcast put your camera a lot
closer and have it more intimate and I
was like okay no no no no no I got I got
a GoPro rolling so is this gonna be a
fully encompassing podcast you're gonna
be on this okay okay you're effecting
change at a grassroots level that's what
that is
are you gonna take this well nobody's no
but it could be no because what she does
is if you don't look at her she'll start
growling oh yeah but like well but
you'll see like as I talk to you you
look at me and just go it's not
threatening yeah and then it turns into
a game with her okay she's fine
okay okay okay okay
hey jerky hi this is you like her we
just roll right into this yeah that's
fine that's beautiful what sir I uh you
haven't been on mine yet have you no but
I've but I I'll probably end up doing
yours right now because I'm obsessed
with so much [ __ ] really I've mastered
obsessions wait for no one's ever
listened if you haven't listened to
Jackie's podcast dork Forrest
it is it is Rangers at the door for us
are my peoples and and they they are
self self-appointed Rangers of the dork
forest but it's super fun because they
are they cracked me up because um my
brother started listening to the show
and none of my family has ever listened
to anything
they're like Oh stand-up comedy I don't
enjoy it but you have a good time and I
was like I don't like money laundering
congratulations whatever you do for a
living and so I mean I don't know how to
talk to people but I
anyone who doesn't do what we do right
so my brother sir listen I got a call
from him yesterday said I have met Sarah
Vowell
I don't know why you don't like there
was a restraining order it was like you
had a giant crush and I was like well
now he's gonna listen cuz I talk about
my yeah yeah well that's the crazy thing
is I forget I forget how I am yeah
on a podcast and I like I've talked
about my there's such a treat for people
yeah I think I think it's like like I
can do stand-up now people are like tell
that story about ila having a hard time
reading and I'm like right and they
heard it on the podcast right and then
and then and sometimes you [ __ ] around
you'll say something that isn't like
you're [ __ ] with your friend yeah
like I said something to re about
something I don't want to bring it up
cuz people talk about all sad well no
they get they bring it up to me all the
time and I don't know what I said but I
know it's not true but I know I was
[ __ ] with re right I just kind of was
like you might have said something some
nightmarish like Lakes like write
something racially or sexually
inappropriate nope no not even
considered considering the conversation
with are you'd think so but the
conversation that something would have
been said that later you went oh I'm
actually not a dick elasti is the last
yeah I believe the last of the people
like I look at your comedy
generationally okay and he's from that
last of the generation of like nope
humph said honesty I say exactly what I
think exactly what I think exactly what
I feel I gotta say at all like
unfiltered 100% cuz I'm not that guy
anymore
I maybe I was when I first started okay
but I definitely am cognizant of the way
my words are perceived well the thing is
all of us have no filter when we first
start we're just trying to get a
reaction from the audience right yeah
you're just like oh I'm gonna be talking
like I had a fascinating bit when I
first started about how I don't know if
you've ever thought of this a great
premise
Batman and Robin might have been gay
because of that pole and the spandex
Jesus Christ patient anyway I mean you
know I was just saying anything really
yeah to get any sort of I was like let's
talk about the inside of my vagina I'll
talk about the inside my ear I've
[ __ ] it but now that I've been doing
it for 1 million years I need I I have
some filter it's not great
it's not always and I attend to say
things like but whatever but uh the but
I do want there to be a [ __ ] punch
line it is not just shock jock stuff
anymore like I have a joke about how I
would rather vote
I hate Scott Walker I die used to the
governor of my state and I he's
destroying my public school system that
I went through and got a pretty good
education and he's destroyed it now
wait and then I say that I would rather
vote for Bill Cosby for president then
Scott Walker because Bill Cosby rapes
people one at a time Bert one at a time
right and so that that is a joke that I
I don't write jokes like that I write
the longest [ __ ] stories in the world
yeah so I wrote that joke in the mine I
can do that joke anywhere and no no you
can't you can't do that joke anywhere
because people get sad people get sad
about Bill Cosby sad about rape and I'm
like well I'm gonna do it anyway because
I wrote that job yes but so I get what
are you saying but I want there to be a
punchline there just has to be it just
be no filter I agree I I used to I mean
I think some people mistake when you're
early on they mistake young comics
mistake aggressiveness and confidence
and fearlessness for sense of humor
right like I would take big swinging
chances I was fearless
I'm not saying I'm fearful now but I
definitely you ever since a proportion
it isn't it isn't fear you can say Bert
Kreischer can say whatever he wants
right I mean and you do I think but
there's but you you there has to be a
nice it's got a it's got to have a twist
it's kind of there's got to be some
point to it does that make sense
and by the way and I'll say it on the
other side of the fence in that I've had
non-aggressive pointless stories that
are just [ __ ] pointless but I'm
sitting there going like last night I
had this I this bit about scuba diving
I'm trying to talk about anxiety in my
stand-up no I'm not trying to be like or
against because I but I believed that
banks that when you have an anxiety
attack it is one of the very few times
in life where you know exactly what you
want and you don't want all right and it
literally is ice cold and burning hot
and you know where you stand
yeah and if you're a baby it's a real
it's very primal its infantile almost
it's like and so uh I've been trying to
I've been dealing with that because
working at Travel Channel and I go into
therapy about it and I'm trying to
explore it right and but there's got to
be something funny about it there has to
be you can't just talk about it right
and as opposed to walking well that's
the only way you can deal with it as a
comic is to find the [ __ ] funny
because that will make the anxiety I
mean you have to address it that's what
they say for everybody but as a comic
you have to address it and genuinely I
think in my opinion make it funny well
what we used to do I say we but like
what we used to do I believe when were
younger comics is we found the funny
first and then work backwards when
you're older you go I want to talk about
this subject
let's where is the funny in that right
and you explore for words right I never
have never done any jokes about my
weight or my looks in the first probably
a year and a half and I'll do like a
throwaway line of I'm overweight the
considerate addressed this type of thing
right because I don't have any jokes but
but recently because I because I've
getting more people it's been I'm very
grateful everybody in Hollywood has been
very nice but people are like no I love
what you do can you do something about
what you look like and I'm like I really
don't think I haven't tried
I mean I have genuinely look like some
version of this since I have been 16
years old give or take 20 pounds right
and I've tried all the different things
right where you eat yoga mat food you
hire someone to slap sandwiches out of
your hand you hire someone to poke you
into doing situps
I've done all the thing where you eat no
meat only eat meat I've done all the
things yeah and it doesn't really make a
huge amount of difference and I don't I
can't really tell because I'm not really
a person who looks in the mirror I only
look at the mirror from the neck up like
I'm not looking at my ass here you have
to look at I'm sorry yeah I look neck up
I brush my teeth I brush the front of my
hair and then I head out the door if
there's trouble the front of my head of
my head I deal with the front of it if
there's tree if I've put my shirt on
backwards I get that from you out here
and the word
right I don't get a lot of it but then I
was thinking about cuz mostly I've just
done what Americans do which is throw
money at it yeah and I will continue to
throw money at it as much as the market
can bear to try to [ __ ] fix this and
it's Oprah but I was thinking about
Oprah who has thrown all the money right
she has all the money yeah and she's
throwing more money than all of us at it
and yet think about it
Oprah kind of looks like this she looks
like me and the only difference is she
has enough money that she has people who
go well you can't go out looking like
that so they push her back into the
house and redo her hair and her and her
teeth and her clothes and you know she's
got and I don't my 40 grand a year is
not gonna be able to match her 40
billion a year it's just not gonna be
able to do it and the real problem that
I actually do have to address is the
fact that it's a math problem I eat all
of I don't eat [ __ ] I just eat all of it
I ate all of the very beautiful organic
foods that are put in front of me the
math problem is exactly it's it's so
simple
I remember by saying to Bobby Kelly one
time you look great man how'd you lose
weight he said I ate less calories and I
burned like yeah and I things be a dick
but he's not he's just saying he was
just saying so genuinely I eat a nice
big breakfast and then just hours later
a big lunch pieces of fruit during the
day and then a dinner guest I do I have
a nice big dinner it's America I don't
know how to I mean I wish I and some
years are better than other years where
I eat less and I lose 20 but sometimes I
wish I could get to the place where
sometimes I'm aware I'm very aware of
the calories sometimes I'm not and a few
mean it seems like I'm doing and I start
losing weight naturally yes just like
I'm very active and then like this I'm
going through a stent right now I'm the
biggest I've ever been and it is and
it's it's for me I'm the opposite of you
I'm very aware of my weight gain and if
you're in it and I'm in it and I end and
it's like I'm panic eating and I mean
I'm drinking I drink a lot so that is
one of the biggest and like I just
switched to vodka male model told me
it's in his contract to drink vodka soda
and I was like oh really that's what I
remember
because when I first moved here I was
only drinking I just gotten my first DUI
when I first moved to Los Angeles get
out there when I got it I was like I I
had switched I was like I'm not gonna
have shots I'm not gonna drink because I
drink like I genuinely I drink I have a
problem with alcohol
and so I don't I don't drink anymore
because I'm on you not drinking for
years for like over over 15 years
oh yeah because and that's what I do I
do the thing where you have to like all
I wanted because I don't I have an
addictive personality I guess because
when I start drinking I don't stop
drinking and I also want to drink like
someone on the Travel Channel right like
I want to match you shot for shot and
then go out and find women and I'm
straight no I want to drink like a man
and then go find a woman you started
stand-up in that I want to say like in
that culture like I'm gonna be now - but
I mean yes in the 80s is when I started
like I want your honest I mean I know
you give me your honest opinion but I
want to say this but and I don't mean
this to sound like I don't mean this to
sound like you've been doing it a long
time because you have you've been doing
innocence count the 80s is one year but
I started in 84 so and but what I find
fascinating about that is you have
maintained in a business that tears
through talent and in a weird way the
industry has changed I would say more to
your personality
oh not so beautiful it is one of the
when I moved I move to Los Angeles I
think in 97 right and it was the height
of or the beginning of that alt thing
like Janeane Garofalo and patton and
paul of Tompkins and Karen kill Gareth
all those people they were storytelling
comics they they somebody asked me in 98
was 98 my buddy KP Anderson you might
know but in Minneapolis comic yeah and
I'm a Minneapolis comic so we started in
Madison right right Madison Wisconsin
and then because I'm from Wisconsin and
then but the the crazy thing about KP
was in because he had lived here for a
couple of years and he was like
yeah I want to do some of those all
tearooms because we're comics we want to
do every [ __ ] room there is any room
I don't care is there a laundromat
that's doing stand-up comedy can I get a
work in right and so he's like but they
won't book me because I'm not
alternative what is that and I genuinely
I said as far as I can tell you tell the
story of how you wrote the joke and then
you tell the punchline that you came up
with and because that is how I have
always done stand-up comedy yeah and
because it's not it's not that there
aren't punchlines adult comedy in 1998
and 19 2000 it's just you get there by
the bull securities route and I chatting
[ __ ] Magoo keishon have always been
the longest talker in the world every
joke I've written has started out as six
minutes it's so funny I never I never
when I started I knew who you were and I
never it's it considered you an alt
comic and all and I still they don't but
I do know that the because they move
towards me exactly but I do know I do I
was aware that people like you who are
working clubs were also at times
swimming upstream against your natural
habits your natural your natural talents
okay like you were forced you were
forced into a mold of a comic where you
wanted to do something you were
naturally doing something very different
than everyone else was doing yeah and
well and what I did like what night or
like you know when you do Yoda and
Muller and sort of dribble out here but
I mean it's there one night or runs and
what you do is you drive from night to
night and you do stand-up
those are there's six career drunks
sitting at the bar trying to play trivia
and you have come into their world and
you do stand-up and and that is that is
not for people are saying that is not
all friendly at all at all and so you
have to figure out a way to to reach
them and so I did and one of the ways I
did it and it's something that I've
tried to undo is I talk very fast
onstage I tell I'm more than willing to
do an hour of material in 20 minutes if
and I'm like you can [ __ ] laugh later
you can laugh later cuz right now I've
got to fulfill my contractual obligation
it's good I need this $125
the hell it is right and so it isn't it
is an ideal but it does I mean it
teaches you all every room you go up a
teaches you a different weird old lesson
it's those rooms are so good I always
try and and I I don't I don't like the I
don't I mean I don't I don't dislike it
I mean it makes a lot of sense the
traditional stand-ups and verses all
stand-ups I've always been more fond I
mean I've always fit in better
in traditional stand-up rooms like
hanging with those people
oh right but I always artistically I
found the alt club's more what I do
right tonight and I know people probably
go really I'm a storyteller and yeah
stand-up comedy clubs doing seven
minutes in stand-up comedy club is not
conducive for me and what I do like I
went to the comedy store and I was like
and they're like seven minutes and I was
like okay that's one story that's one
story it's actually at this point it's
one story plus a minute I don't know
what to do with which is so irritating
because I'm like well okay I'll do that
one bit and I was like but I'd but I
have the hardest time just as throwing
it's like throwing away money yeah what
to throw away that minute like well I
guess I'll be running the light what did
somebody somebody said to me they said
okay it's a ten minute set and I said
I'm so sorry I have to six minute bits
I'll be doing twelve minutes and she
just looked at me and she said really
and I said yeah is that all right and
she goes well now that I know yeah
that's fine I was in uh I was in
Montreal and they were like so you're
doing I guess seven minutes or I think
was seven minutes I'm some TV taping
alright and I go great and he goes so
weird when do you want your light and I
go oh I there's no giving me the light
when the story's over I'll finish it
right maybe cut it into whatever chunks
you lose like we would mean I go when
I'm done with the story you'll you'll
see I'll go thank you that is the best
by the way I did it was a couple years
ago I did one of those shows it was HBO
it was the HP of Canada version of some
damn show I said what I did okay so they
were like well what's your last line and
so I think what's your last line and I
was like I don't know I Judah
Friedlander told me to do exactly what
you just said which is thank you
goodnight yeah because I told them the
actual last line of the joke and they
cut
the last punchline I wanted to choke
everyone involved and really yeah the
poor woman she just started the music
over the last punch line and I was like
alright then I do that cat joke and the
last line is meow meow or something who
knows what the [ __ ] it is but it's and
that's the last line and I get offstage
and judo's like oh I should have told
you you should always say the last line
is thank you goodnight because then they
don't screw up any of your jokes yes
like okay
note to self and note to all comics
listening cuz it's a learned skill you
do you know they still paid me it's a no
offense those things I know no interest
I'm I have very little interest in doing
short sets these days unless I'm working
on a story and I really kind of just
want to work on the story like I really
like like um like open mic rooms yeah I
love them going in there and just going
hey the bar is not that high no one
knows who I am
alright I'm not saying that people know
who I am anyway but like if I go say I
go to the but you can kind of strongarm
your way into a not three minutes set
right is that what you do is because
that's what I it is oh sorry
young new comics if I go to an open mic
I'm like can I please have six minutes
yeah and but I don't but I don't run the
light like I'm not I don't Damon Wayans
the damn thing yeah and just keep going
like I did I did a show at the emperor
of the other night where you get to pick
everyone right where it's Jackie Kashian
and Friends it was called yeah and so I
picked five comics that I wanted to see
well day of I get an email from the
improv hey Todd Barry's looking for a
set tonight we said he could do 10
minutes during your set and I was like
well I love Todd Barry
fine I'll cut and I was supposed to do
40 minutes I was supposed to get to but
I was hosting luckily so I was like okay
well I'll do 10 and 30 and it'll be fine
and I was like okay well I'll do 10 and
20 fine and then I get to the club and
Jay Leno and Judd Apatow are like hey we
want to do guess it and I was like
they're not my friends and Friends and
so did you want to I wouldn't mind being
your friend set up time you got to put
the target
you gotta have like lunch or something
you're not even gonna reintroduce me to
Jimmy Miller who doesn't remember who I
am no fair enough
okay well then we are not friends but we
could be friends if we are I don't need
to be in your movie though if you need a
PTA mom this is available so but the
yeah but obviously you can't say no to
Jay Leno and Judd Apatow Yeah right
because the audience will be psyched but
I didn't get to do any time yeah I did I
did a 12 up front cuz that's what I'm
doing these days if I do a short said
I'm so sorry I'm doing 12 and so I did
12 and then I brought up everybody I
wanted to I'm on my team right that I
enjoy Maria Bamford
well I asked a lot of people who were
famous who could have filled the room a
little bit better like I would love to
have you good because but I ended up
with the greatest what cuz they're so
we're in a Golden Age of stand-up comedy
right now you could pick there's 50
people at any given moment that I will
stay in the room and watch there's a lot
of really good comics right now I think
somebody's had the best place that's
ever been and I and I think that it's
also allowing the most voices it's ever
allowed yeah like my lineup was Cameron
Esposito oh I know she's gay and she's
smart and she's a side bullet she's
great yeah Baron Vaughn who destroys
yeah the guy he's on a Frankie and grace
Grayson Frankie whatever Netflix with I
think I just know one from stand-up yeah
and he is one he's quite honestly is one
of my favorite comics working today he
is it is so it's a beautiful treat to
watch Baron Vaughn stand up County find
him do whatever you want anyway my buddy
Jim Wooster nobody [ __ ] knows who Jim
moose tourism and he only does stand-up
what I insist that he doesn't end up so
it's always a joy and then it was a
lorry kill Martin Martin amazing comic
and Salomon Giorgio do you know Salomon
Giorgio I know the name he is a tall
also gay black but mine one of my one of
my favorite introductory jokes of his
that he did on Conan last time was I am
a tall very beautiful black man
so I am a waiter in West Hollywood and
he talks in this very measured kind of
hello and and he immigrated with his
parents from Ethiopia when he was like
12 and so he has this sort of there's
just so many different somebody I have
really had I had a really good time at
Montreal this year watching people would
you get to see that was just a treat but
there's two different things
there's treats and then there's people
that I like I got there's I don't know
what this feeling is it's it's it's
inspiration it's it's it's somewhat
jealousy at the fact that I'm not
working that hard okay Sebastian
Maniscalco
oh right you know what I have seen him
once and I can't picture him but I
remember his name wait Italian right
alien I saw his long set at punch line
and it was talking about a goddamn treat
that guy was amazing he is he told a
story he told a story that that had no
real like it wasn't like like re re and
I ended up the next day talking about
story about good stories and what you
need for a good story and like kind of
obsessing about a little bit and his
story was was okay but it destroyed and
it had me dying laughing because yes
he's he's [ __ ] worked the muscle that
he knows how to be funny he knows
subtlety he plays like a violent God
like like like a like a virtuoso and I
was i watched him and i was like oh my
god because you look at him what i
looking at him i I was like well that
guy's little bro II and then I watched
him do an hour and in the course of that
hour one of the things that was the most
beautiful thing in the world for me was
how much he clearly like loved his wife
oh yeah and how OCD and sort of twitchy
he is I mean that's what many of us he's
very OCD in real life and it is it was
the revelation I mean that's what I want
to see like Jay Leno the other night did
a story about being kind of an old guy
and and he said you know
you hit on women and/or you flirt with
women and then he told a story about how
Jay Leno flirts with women and it is one
of the sweetest things
like you'd never have any idea what the
hell Jay Leno was like from his stand-up
because he's very jokey right it's very
like this is how Jay Leno hits on women
this is Jay Leno's idea of flirting he's
driving his gajillion dollar car he sees
a pretty woman at a car next to him and
he smiles at her and she smiles back and
he's like that can make my day you guys
and I was like wow that is the nicest
cat call ever you know like I'll just
I'll see it pretty woman and I'm like
hello and she'll say hello back and I'm
like she said hi to me and you're like
oh my god you're awesome I just it made
me like Jay Leno like I haven't since
1990 I'm always impressed
I'm always it I'm always impressed when
a guy like that like I said this is
probably now it has to be at least 11
years ago 10 years ago when dice wasn't
working I think he's working his angle
was it was just working you I I don't I
can't I don't know all I know is it and
I don't want to speak of Dicer or about
his career I don't know anything about
his career Jami I know that I was a fan
of when we were younger and he blew it
up and then he like I went through some
hard times I think but maybe not I maybe
we close we're in the road
anybody wasn't working Madison Square
Garden at this right and and he was in
the green room at the Comedy Store I was
only there because Louie Anderson asked
me to do like he was doing Sunday nights
it was like I want I want to say and
then memories always [ __ ] incorrect
but one state was like Roseanne Barr
Chris Rock Andrew Dice Clay Louie
Anderson myself Steve Byrne and Brian
Scholl are oh like that's insane
and and Andrew Dice Clay was telling a
story about taking his kids to the park
and having to bring the bikes and and it
was so funny he wasn't trying to be
funny he was just telling about his day
in the green room in the green room and
he was like what a baby like the kids
apparently didn't want they packed the
bikes the bikes I got the [ __ ] bikes
the things hidden me in the shin I got
him in the trunk but still like he's
complaining about putting bikes in the
truck
it's Andrew Dice Clay complaining about
it and so and then he's getting this
thing where the kids aren't even riding
the bikes and he goes I'm sitting by the
car one
the bikes and you're like why would you
do that on stage every time you talk and
everyone goes nuts and they go nuts but
you're like but that was a beautiful
story please tell that story again
there's an insight about you that I am
blessed to have shared the everybody
everyone wants to hear that story dice
you always tell the story before you're
a human being
cuz that's my favorite kind of comedy I
mean you look at like like Kyle Kinane
and and any any you know anybody where
you're like even like even know we won't
be saying whatever after even I was like
even Mike Birbiglia feels like a Dickey
thing to say because per billion I
always think of he doesn't know this
he's my arch enemy because I I have I
yeah because I feel like he's not really
but I mean it's like I feel I love his
career because he's like this darling of
that NPR set and I like they would love
me if they knew me like if I were glass
liked me if Nathan Lane wanted to I
don't know maybe touch me I might uh I'm
such a dick but I don't know but I think
that it's like it's I think that they
would they would lend them you get what
you get in this business right and I
feel so grateful and blessed to get to
do it for a living yeah that I and I do
have to work on it I mean I think we all
have to work on not being bitter and or
angry it's tough it's tough not to go
like tonight I'll tell you I'll tell you
my honest feeling was like I hate I hate
that I look the way I look because I
can't work in UCB and I think I do very
well in that room you would do it and
the thing is is you look like half of
the guys who work UCB know but when you
come from a different come from a
different background you come from
there's a there's a lateral move that
would be hard because people would be
like oh it's that guy yeah and you're
like [ __ ] you yeah it turns out I talked
out of my joke-hole and tell jokes and
you would enjoy them there's a lot of
clubs I'd like to work because I'd like
to and I'd like to work differently than
I normally would were like but just just
like to [ __ ] around and have a good time
I look like I look like a homophobic
you look a little you come from sort of
the bro east side a standard I have a
friend I have a friend who I who I will
not mention big Lea okay names on ahed
okay
and she Romanian I think she's half yeah
no I think she's half Iranian half
Christian I think I'm not sure
yeah that's Armenian anyway go ahead she
said we were trying to put this project
together yeah and she said yeah it's
like I was I need
she called me a broke ohmic and I was
never heard that before so Ken's there's
a lot of bro comics that I was listening
to and she is not like she is I mean
probably uber like I don't want it I'll
tell you off air more yeah but like
she's like hardcore feminist liberal
like an NPR type Yepsen and she but I
heard bro comics know what that's really
interesting and I was like you know I
think the bro comic thing gets such a
such a bad rap but it's you know what it
is is that bro comics always fit in at
the funny bones and the improv with the
bro managers and the bro waitstaff right
and games with the programmers made and
you know it's just it's like that but
there's bro comics and then there's like
slow clap jock program bro comics right
like what the slow clap jock guys are
like no I wanna it's like it's like the
Hardwick you know it's like Chris
Hardwick or J Moore or guys who are like
no yeah I'm a nerd I'm a giant nerd you
guys don't get this and they want to
hang out with nerds but they are also
like like sort of [ __ ] kind of like
them but also they're like but I'm not
an [ __ ]
so why it's not my fault that [ __ ]
like me can I please perform for people
that aren't [ __ ] and it's I'm not
saying that yeah I know but there's
there's certain there's different kinds
of comedy fans and that and the horrible
comedy fans at UCB are sort of the
certain kickback he kind of like hipster
II kind of guys who are like you don't
do a joke that I think you wrote
did you wait did you work on that and
you're like yeah I worked on it it turns
out that's what I do for a living I
write jokes I am a monkey for your
entertainment and don't make me there's
a fair amount in the in what is left of
the altie comedy scene where you have to
appear like you're not trying yeah but
you're like oh like did you ever see the
fantastic mr. Fox yeah one of the
greatest movies in the world but he
nailed it
it's Wes Anderson right so he yeah I sat
through that movie thoroughly enjoying
it and it is a beautiful movie but it
has that laid-back sort of like know me
and my friends just got together on a
weekend you know my friends Meryl Streep
and George Clooney and then we did stop
action video yeah we just threw it
together and you're like no you didn't
this took three years of just head down
nerds
working their asses off yeah and it is
gorgeous and beautiful and you should be
proud of it and he is proud of it but he
is nobody has nailed that laid back like
no I just I just made a diamond out of
out of nothing more than Wes Anderson
and it's something that it's I don't
know how to define it except for by that
for that very long story see you guys
see you guys later
it's been great talking but no I know
you mean III like there are comics that
you feel like they are putting it
together like like stanhope someone
every time I watch Stanhope yeah I feel
like he's just putting it together as he
comes up with it and then he's very
adamant about them no no that's why I
present the material I'm working on this
[ __ ] right yeah
yeah if there's it's like whenever
somebody says they're like why they
wonder about people's worth it work
ethic because they make it look so easy
Oh people think I'm people think I you
the biggest slacker in the world and I
go no no I literally stayed up all night
last night like I woke up at 3:00
thinking about this joke this
scuba-diving thing and I was like I'm
not putting the work in this and then I
was like what is scuba diving
technically and I started trying to
break it down and then like the like I
started like trying to describe
everything like go back that's one of
the things that really good comics do is
they take
a little detail and just [ __ ] blow it
up and I was like I was like okay let me
[ __ ] work and so I was up all night
working on this joke in my head I mean
this way my process and then I do that
and then I take it onstage and I work on
it there yeah but yeah that's
let's but it's you know people say it
about Bamford Marines one of my best
friends it has been four CC okay the way
you feel about Ira Glass those feel
about Maria Bamford oh is that you want
her to like her there's a bunch of
people that I just never really clicked
in that scene but like I really enjoy
watching her yeah for me for my money
she's the best working comic like I
listen like nobody comes up with topics
that she does nobody but and people
they're like wool well I want to you
know there's this attitude of like well
she's kind of flaky and you're like I
don't think you understand how much work
goes into what the [ __ ] she's doing well
she's she's very honest I loved the
podcast you guys there were you guys
eight of Hugo's it's just it's really
cool because it's like it's like being a
fly on the wall really yeah and and but
he was so sick of doing podcasts at that
point that I asked her if she wanted to
do my podcast she said only if I get to
interview you about the things that
you'd never talked about which is and
then she just grilled me about chicken
and romance novels yeah which and I
don't and it's funny I do a bit about
romance novels now that I that I because
that that that episode of the dork
forest is probably three years old now
four years old and so right after that I
started working on that bit and that bit
turned into like a signature bit but I
never would have admitted because nobody
wants to hear that people people read
romance novels but now I see
because maybe cuz because I do that bit
that a fan send me articles they're like
oh people are lauding romance novels
dawn I was like well they shouldn't be
lauding them coolest thing about
podcasting is that you put out there
what you like that's what I love about
yours you put out there what you like or
what you're obsessed about and then
people send you oh did you know about
this and you did it and then I forward
it to whoever like they're like oh did
you do you love that vice-presidential
like there was a guy that was just under
talked about all the vice of vice
presidents he's a vice presidential nerd
and you're like well first of all that's
hilarious
yeah second of all that's fascinating
had these weird stories like about
McKinley's first vice-president the guy
before Teddy Roosevelt and you're like
what guy died and then Teddy Roosevelt
take his place
yes yeah oh yeah don't get me on Teddy
Roosevelt I'm obsessed with that
[ __ ] oh that guy what a
psychopath I I was like I was what a
psychopath he people to understand this
guy went down the he had his horses
taken from New York all the way down to
Cuba so he could fight in the what is it
was a dispenser the spanish-american war
than any tourist rated Brooks Brothers
suits and he meanwhile there are real
soldiers in this war and he shows up out
of a catalog yes and then parades
himself around but like a j.crew guy
yeah I went through an obsession with
him I go through these obsessions and
then and what I do is I listen to stuff
while I sleep I got my exceptions date
my lose your wife I'm on the road I'm on
the road Oh fair enough
35 days a month Oh fair enough
ridiculous so I listen right now my
sessions David Foster Wallace mmm and so
I'm listening to every interview that
he's ever done and I'm listening to oh
that's - I had a David Foster Wallace
dork on Josh kondal Minh you know he
writes for John Oliver show New York I
really funny really funny guy and he
loved David Foster Wallace and the thing
is is I was like oh the Honduras
Thompson of your generation I get it
and so because I never I didn't know who
the I didn't know he was and and I
called him George Wallace twice during
the podcast different person yeah yeah
I'm going through that obsession right
now I'm going through I have a this is
they hate my dogs are obsessed with
[ __ ] garbagemen right they're like
you guys dealing with the the debt Reyes
of humanity can't handle it and I can't
handle the truth Mona Mona Mona Mona
Mona Mona Mona was brought up in the
barrio
she was a rescue from the barrio so she
had a fear of Mexican men many times she
saw a Mexican guy she'd lose her [ __ ]
[ __ ]
which is semi problematic in the city
where there's a lot of everyone is you
know it's funny it's my in-laws are from
a little town up in the Central Valley
of California yeah just that crazy it's
a it's I don't know if you ever saw a
can of Olives
Lyndsay olives they live in Lindsay
California I know I know where all those
olive trees are I know you're talking
about
it's just olives and oranges and meth
and it's sweet and and my and my in-laws
and they uh my husband as lesbian moms
and they've been together for almost 40
years yeah yeah so they were lesbian
moms before lesbian moms were cool you
guys and they always find those people
so fascinating they are two of their the
nicest women in the world and but when I
met Andy stepmom Fran I was like so what
do you what do you do for a living Fran
and she goes I work a forklift at a
cheese factory here in town and I could
not stop laughing and I said say it
again friend it's a little stereotypical
friend you work a forklift at a cheese I
know more lesbian I've no more lesbians
than anybody I know I don't know but the
the but they are the sweetest people but
one so one time you know we visit them
fairly often because it's just a couple
hours away and what there's one
Starbucks in this little town yeah and
so I'm like hey I'm gonna take a walk to
the coffee shop and I get lost I have no
sense of direction I get lost in New
York in numbered grid streets I get lost
I have the I have a magnet next to the
compass in my brain so I get lost and
all of a sudden I'm in just this
apartment kind of area it might be the
projects it might be whatever it is it
doesn't matter it's Lindsay there's I'm
not naked running with money taped to my
ass yes and and I'm not an attitude
person so nobody's gonna give me any
[ __ ] except for I get chased by a pack
of tiny wild feral dogs Oh little
[ __ ] chihuahuas and and mutt
chihuahuas who were biting at me and
these two women were sitting on their
porch where I'm just like I'm about to
have words with tiny dogs I'm about to
kick a [ __ ] dog and it's and there's
gonna be witnesses and I'm gonna feel
like a jerk
but I cannot be bit by ducks I cannot
it's not something I wish to happen in
my life that was Mona Mona was uh one of
those wild feral dogs yeah and so I say
to the two women I was like can you call
these dogs off and they laugh and they
go they're not our dogs and I was like
yeah but you know these [ __ ] dogs
yeah you can call these dogs off and
they're like yeah we can call us I'll
tell you can't tell me what okay tell me
if what I'm saying is is um I don't know
if it's like I don't know maybe it's
sexist but like I believe that I believe
um let me restart let me start off with
nothing I believe okay cuz my wife is my
wife this is one of my argument I have
of my wife okay I think sometimes not
all the times whatever I even know how
to talk these days just say [ __ ] and now
I'm so cognitive the fact that people's
feelings are attached to these and
they're listening listening good for you
I'm you doing what you can
I'm one of the more empathetic people
these days but that's through therapy
right honestly okay and my wife um but
like my well let me just put it this way
my wife has no etiquette with dogs
meaning like if she's walking our dog
and our dog wants to go over and sniff
in your daughter's in care actual area
no carry it's like in a baby in a
stroller
my wife will let the dog go over and I
go no that's not how dogs work no no and
that's not how your your I'm so sorry
dogs are dogs and people are people yeah
and you are a dog owner yeah I am sorry
the emancipation of dogs is not yet
complete you have to control and curb
your dog thank you and and I but I feel
like what I noticed I loved on what I
notice is that women are more apt to
just be like okay as opposed to men cuz
and but I think that's the think this is
my theory is why we whittled it down if
I had those those social blinders on
where I could just let my dog walk over
and smell you yeah the dad then may get
upset with me and there might be an
altercation right if my dog does
something there will then be an
altercation whereas women that don't
have that fear of an immediate
altercation that's a good theory the
ears ears without this is my
favorite thing about comics you'd ask
for any opinion I don't have any
information on this but I will have an
opinion your friend oh yeah let's do it
my opinion is that this is and this is
sweeping but I think this is all
sweeping it right so my theory is that
men are more conscious of how they are
viewed as sort of not predators but
predators right they're more there's
there's an aggressive testosterone thing
that they are raised with where you're
like men just by their nature are
considered more threatening so when you
were walking your dog you were aware
that the threat that you are as a man
and that your dog might be as a dog yeah
when a woman is walking a dog she might
not be aware that she and her dog are a
threat
okay that sounds fair that might be that
is my theory without thinking it through
anybody got anything Iran nobody what's
the Hat you remember the hashtag yes all
women yes oh by the way I'm talking
about my one friend a lot this podcast
yeah but we were talking about that I
never realized that by the way and I I
read yeah I regret for every man man who
would who fought that and said well you
ever know but all men well that's not
the [ __ ] point of this the point was
just simply do [ __ ] open these shades so
that you could see just how sometimes
people feel that's it's that's it not to
say that yes all men are aggressive
animals what yes all women does and all
and black lives matter it is a water
that fish live in that you do not live
it right
it is the pond that you didn't you are
you were also in that pond but you are a
different kind of fish yeah so the I
this isn't I Jackie Kashian
I'm not Helen of Troy right I do not
inspire though I'm hot you guys have a
wild cat in the sack that's not that's
actually not true I am a hard-working
and earnest in the sack makes up for a
lot so but I even I have been
actually attacked sexually I've had to
have I've been a date raped I've had all
the horrible things that have happened
to me and this is and I live a little
defensively but I don't live in fear
I wrote when yesallwomen came out I
wrote a blog I will repost it you guys
cuz I am fascinating but here's here's
my revelation and the exact same think
is you don't know the weird [ __ ] that I
go through and the weird defensiveness
that I live through I have always been a
liberal white lady yeah so I have always
been sympathetic to the black experience
now here because of cell phones and
because of the videos that come out
every [ __ ] week now there is it is
surprising to be that black people talk
about anything else but their experience
but they don't because that is the water
in which they live in you can't talk
about the thing I can't talk about
sexism every [ __ ] moment of the day
because I have a life to lead I need to
eat a sandwich I got a go I don't have
to talk about any of that right because
there's a white guy you don't have to
deal with those things any of it right
you have other issues it doesn't mean
that anyone's handing you 20s my issues
now I'm not saying I'm not by the way
I'm not trying to glance over the
difficulties it is that life is for
everyone but like I don't do I deal with
whatever stuff I deal with you got to
deal with also right and then you got to
deal with that other [ __ ] too right
there's another layer and it's the the
the fact that and and I was I was
talking about some comics the other day
I was Augie Smith and Andy would you
know this guy's whatever but we're
having lunch and I was like you know
what's weird that I lost it [ __ ]
the train of thought it's weird about
sexism men know about about the Oh
community how you know we are humans and
there is a black community right now the
black community is an artificial
construct it's a but it's a constant
made for the protection of black people
but if you think about people as people
what if you were black
you're like but that guy's I don't like
him but I have to be kind of supportive
of him because he's another black guy
and you're like that is a whole other
level of having to hang out with people
that it's like comics yeah like I some
some comics I don't like them I don't
but I had a very vocal about that oh I
know like people because for the most
part I do like people yeah and and I but
and I make sure to tell comics if I like
their new stuff and I like whatever
comics yeah and but there's there's some
comics that they they just wear me out
and I just think of his work friends and
I can't but they do get to say whatever
they want to say yeah you know and I
will defend that right and and if
there's if there's a heckler situation
oh my god I've said horrible things to
hecklers horrible things that I would
apologize to if I ran into him and I
said mean things I've said things that
I've said things and lost the entire
crowd then and then I'm like and and I
and I by the way I regret saying look I
was put in a position where I tried to
add to had to make [ __ ] lemonade out
of lemons yes and and I was how I made
the [ __ ] lemonade I'm sorry if I
stirred it with my dick right and nobody
recorded it and so I don't have to make
a public thank God emulation of it but
the but the craziness is is that I would
apologize like if there was a guy 20
years ago who was horrible and would not
shut up and finally I made some crack it
was it was a terrible thing I said a
terrible thing to the man about his his
infant child and you may imagine what
horrible thing I said and he was like
hey that's going too far and I said yes
it is will you please shut up because I
did in the moment know that it was too
far yeah yeah yeah please shut up I'm
working I'm trying to entertain the
other nine people that are in the room
yeah ever it is right it's interesting I
always find is that I think that um that
in those situation I would comic and I
go listen you don't know what it's like
to be there 100
I say actually that's not true like
sometimes if it's done
there there are times when you're like
well you didn't have to name the person
that's that's not you know yeah but when
it's like if it's Tosh at the comedy you
know when you go to see a comedy show
American public or anywhere in the world
please look up a youtube video make sure
you know what you're going into because
it's not it may not be for you a comedy
is not for everybody I always say to
everyone I like I'll think of a joke in
my in my head and then I'll start
giggling and they'll go say it say no
that's not for you I promise you I know
what you like and what you don't like
better than you do right trust me when I
say you will not enjoy this I like this
I could tell the Jackie I can tell if
Dodge
I cannot tell to you Bamford opens her
act with this whole thing about how her
parents took her to see they're like you
like Spielberg we're going to see War
Horse and she's like War Horse as far as
I could tell at the end of it was a
documentary about how to kill a horse I
would like to say to you is that I Maria
Bamford might be your war horse I am NOT
for everybody and if it is so take take
a leaflet out of Martin Luther King out
of Gandhi and and March but go to the
bar with the people what's wrong with
the people that that byung humble become
obstinate and arrogant that they don't
like you almost as if like like and I'll
use Maria as an example yeah almost as
if Maria
they believed that Maria doesn't want
them to like her right like oh my god we
all want you to like us [ __ ] I want
everyone to like me I want people I
don't like to want to let there's people
that I that that I don't like only
because they don't like me yeah oh
that's every [ __ ] situation I've ever
had in a club if there's one person not
smiling I'm like please let that person
[ __ ] like oh man your wife dragged
you and I'm so sorry and I'll find
myself focusing on the 68 year old woman
who I know is not driving with my
material and I'll go man this one's for
you [ __ ] what is wrong with wine what
what
um I'll in case you don't want to talk
about this at all but okay but um you
and you don't have to ever 50 minutes
just all I remember um do you how do you
go through something like like sexual
assault and not have it define your
voice oh right well a couple of things
first of all I was stand up wise I was
raised up in stand up in the generation
where you were not even supposed to
mention that you were a woman and had
bodily functions yes because you were
Wisconsin and it was all it was Kinnison
like I said there was Sam Kinison and
Steve Morrell and and all of these sort
of these iconic comics who were who were
dark and edgy and stuff like that and
guys could talk about their dick so they
could talk about the stuff that comes
out of their dicks and the stuff that
comes out of their asses but as a woman
Connick you were not allowed to talk
about your menstrual cycle and you
weren't allowed to talk about getting
laid too much you could say it in
passing and so I ended up writing a lot
of jokes about sort of my inner life
like my brain and so I you weren't
allowed to talk about sexual assault in
the last 15 years a lot of women there's
more women doing comedy and so much like
when more people start doing it you feel
okay talking about like the real things
in your life yeah like Cameron Esposito
has a joke about her period that is
hilarious
and weirdly uncomfortable to me because
I'm like oh is she allowed to talk with
it anyway but yeah she is it turns out
because it's her ten minutes you can do
it over the [ __ ] she wants with it turns
out they'll be in on the comic um hey
I've heard some really good period jokes
great we're going cuz Georgia my old my
oldest is is 11 and the idea that your
period will show up one day yeah is his
possibility and but it's interesting I
mean we talked about we had a whole
dinner by the way make it a thing
Donnelly said you need a go-bag because
if it shows up in school try to go baby
I you don't I don't I don't know what
that's like
yeah I know for a fact that when it did
happen to the
when we were boys and she wasn't it she
didn't have a go back and and we were
like we were like oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
what's-her-name's got her period and so
I said you know boys are like and so we
it was a really great talk so I was like
I was like I don't mind more
conversations I don't mind more stand-up
with different things other than just
[ __ ] which I love talking about a
fisting joke that has done well weird
with style and panache please write that
joke but the sexual is something the
weird thing is I did write a joke
because I am in the first relationship
of my life I have always done stand-up
and always been alone and then just
gotten laid because that's what I
thought comics did you thought that it
was like the program I same way and I
thought I mean I'm gonna say the
person's name to love him but like I
just assumed that me and Gary Valentine
would be 7 years old playing golf single
until the day we died that's it that's
and you just you're single and then I
the most of the comics I met on the road
the first 10 years I was on the road
they cheated on their wives I remember
the first guy I met who didn't cheat on
his wife I still remember his name his
name is Fred Colette KL ett I believe he
does cruise ships now and he is a
wonderful comic and he is a decent human
being
I never my never worked with anyone that
no cheat on their wives and for me
falling in love and not wanting to cheat
I was like how does this work
right how does it work and so but about
10 or 11 years ago I was like you know
what I would like a rest of a life and
so I an online dating was invented so it
was an amazing thing but so I am in this
weird I am in this relationship for the
first time in my life and not every so I
do a bit about how not every sexual
experience I have had has been a
positive sexual experience and so
sometimes when you have a lot of sex
with the same person which I have never
done before yeah me and my husband we're
constantly going at it it's awesome
yeah anyway it's the time of my life yes
so but sometimes he will poke me in a
way that will remind me of a negative
experience and then I do a story about
how then I'm crying and then he's
screwing someone who's crying and when
you're having sex with someone who's
crying
as a woman you just have a couple of
choices you can lie there stoically
silent tears coursing down your face and
he may or may not notice but he ruts
like it's a Dickens novel
or you can talk to him like a person you
can do both quite honestly which is what
I did and then we'll have the
conversation and so then we have the
conversation and it's the funny angle to
it is the fact that my husband is a
video game designer a board game
designer view a card game designer
everything is a game everything is a
game mechanic everything could be fixed
in life including jury duty and urban
planning with game mechanics so he is
hilarious in that so I tell him I'm like
well that was a sad thing and we're
gonna need III just gonna need a minute
to regroup and he's like yeah or we
could fix it with game mechanics we
could LARP it out and I'm like what is
happening and so to de LARP is to live
action
oh no warped you've LARP of course did
you learn we did zombie apocalypse oh
very funny
it was it was one of the funnest things
I've ever [ __ ] done in my entire life
it didn't make for great TV but it was
the one of the coolest things I've ever
done and I got lost in it and I thought
it's like playing army when you're a kid
and just and I thought I and I go it's
so funny that LARPing was the it was the
it was the the impetus of mock mockery
larper he's a larper and yet if you do
it and you can you even if you don't
commit you have that I have done
starship Valkyrie is a is a is a sort of
a Star Trek II one that they run every
month really that you can just do you
sign right up I think it's $25 you guys
and then they give you a character you
can make your own character you do
whatever you want and and you go out
into space and you fight bad guys so and
II ran a LARP at our house based on the
TV show Deadwood and don't tell my wife
about this well and two of his we had to
move two of his friends played a Civil
War veterans who had now had a bar in
Deadwood and they were in our they were
in our backyard because it was 30 people
yeah and they're all it takes you know
all day it's essentially if you don't
know what LARPing is it's a it's a it's
a costume party with game mechanics so
there's fear and there's food and it's
actually pretty intricate and it's and
it's very and it's very fun because you
do get lost and care
yeah we do boffin larping which is where
people you fight with swords but my
husband does theater LARPing which is
where there's a storytelling element oh
I thought would be really fun yeah and
so but I had to move his two buddies
from our from where we grill because
they were in character saying horrible
things and I was like guess where the
saloon just got moved to into the garage
yeah so there's a whorehouse and there's
a [ __ ] with a heart of gold those two
guys and then there's the I don't know
if you remember that in the in the TV
show there was a black veteran who
referred to himself as the in general
yeah and and so but whatever it was but
it was super fun and then he's done he's
done three different Sandman lops based
on the Neil Gaiman series Sandman yeah
that was that was the first one I ever
went to Maria and I did that one and for
that one there were 70 people and people
wrote one-act plays of the death of each
of the endless and it was the greatest
thing and Maria and I played extras
what's the Sandman I don't know Sandman
is is a comic book a graphic novel
written by Neil Gaiman
and he and the Sandman was is the dream
guy right he said asleep asleep God and
the endless said there's there's seven
of them nine seven I think it's seven
and uh and it is a great comic book if
you get a chance read Sandman though
purists will say you have to start at
the beginning I say you can start of the
fourth graphic novel you guys really
because there's it's it's 75 that
Lucifer some of the greatest stuff I
have a hard time with comic books um but
I didn't realize I didn't know I was
dyslexic okay it's just I've hard time
reading I've always had a hard time
reading I don't a books on tape but uh
comic books are really tough for me
because I especially and I don't know if
this is all decisis but it's me and my
daughter my daughter's dyslexic to my
daughter so does actually she wrote a
horrible word on her paper the other day
and the teacher grabbed her paper and
ripped it up so you're never to write
that word ever again and she'd even know
what word it was to this day my wife's
trying to talk to the teacher to find
out just might want to tell this lady up
dyslexic since the beginning of school
here
cuz I didn't mean to write anything
right right I was just trying to write
no come here comic books I jump around
like I my I will just jump around I just
I the natural progression of where to
read a bubble or whatever it just
doesn't work for me it's I have that
same problem with manga but that's
probably because I learned to read left
to right like a like an English speaker
the manga is written right to left with
manga manga it's a it's like anime but
comic book II okay so it's Japanese
comic books Japanese comic books are
right-to-left and and and so and you
have to read from the upper right hand
corner to the lower left hand corner and
it is such a mindfuck for me it's but
it's just a learned skill I am not
dyslexic so I could learn it but it's
sort of like learning how to play Halo
on Xbox versus PlayStation you have to
spend a good six hours with the
controller to relearn how to button mash
correctly what um what no I love I love
it an analogy specific and only the
people that love it get it right so but
it is but I but so we'd we LARP doubt my
my sex problem which was he was like so
what we'll do is we'll put a couple of
chairs in the kitchen and we'll pretend
we're on the bus and then the guy that
attacked you on the bus I will go
through it together and we'll reenact it
and I was like gutsy stuff brother and
he's like but it'll be me and we'll look
at well I'll look at you the whole time
and we'll look at each other and we'll
do it to each other and we'll laugh and
we'll cry and my favorite line just like
then at the end you'll be [ __ ] me and
you love me by the way I just I just
kind of fell in love with your husband
yeah there's no reason not to fall in
love with Andy Ashcraft by the way let
me plug something he just wrote a game
that is free so you could go to the hero
instant and the hero instant is an RPG
it's like D&D but super heroes D&D with
super heroes yes I never I could never
get into D&D when I was a kid but I
wanted to so bad I bought all the stuff
it's but I wasn't I wanna read the books
you couldn't David Germain was into it
and we'd go over to his house and I just
and I had all the stuff but I and I but
I love the fantasy I love getting lost
in fantasy but I
I didn't really I didn't really learn
how to I mean this gonna sound really
bad I could always read but I didn't
really learn how to read until my
freshman year of high school meaning
like I found a trick and it was and it
was for I took a speed reading class
okay so I was really I was a really slow
reader and I my reading comprehension
was like zero yeah and the speed reading
class taught me they were like you know
what just pick just let your eyes jump
around and grab a word and piece
together whatever they're trying to say
and so now when I read I'll give the
words and I get the gist of it and I go
okay vacation Fiji snorkel mask shark
other than what scuba diving it was
scuba day they might have run into a
shark yeah exactly yeah okay that's kind
of fascinating yeah that's how I read
though okay that's I don't I think
whatever you got to do quite a bit yeah
and it's nothing it's you know it's like
I can I can read departures and arrivals
I can read fine I've just it's just a
sit read a book for me is extremely
taxing right and it and it makes me more
tired than it does and books on tape are
like I buy it's a gift
yes my brother it's pretty great
it's you know how people are on their
parents Netflix and Friends Netflix I
mean my brother's audible and my
sister's Hulu Plus I'm on my dad's
Amazon products on his own whatever
books a Kindle oh well my dad's Kindle
so I get all my dad's books my dad's a
big history buff yeah yeah and so every
now and then I'll pull up one is I'll go
with this thing and go download the
device download advice and then sit
there and go and I'm not gonna read this
well I mean that's the greatest thing my
brother is will listen to any fantasy
his his criteria cuz he drives he's a
Salesman and he drives all the time is
that it has to be over 26 hours that's
his creature I was like that isn't the
best criteria Phil what I'm gonna need
from you why don't you pick something
then and I was like well I'm gonna pick
nonfiction and I and then he's like
alright well don't use all my credits
but yeah but he's you know he's brother
sees what your family is was was it a
big six kids six kids you're the
youngest
I'm the youngest yeah and what was the
what was the dynamic were you guys like
it was tall boys right for boys and then
my sister and then me and
and was were they like athletic were
they beards were they
stoners mostly cuz yeah my brother Phil
tells this great story about how when he
was 17 he woke up under a bush in South
Milwaukee Wisconsin with just a bottle
of like southern comfort and he was just
he just came to and he was like I want
to be I want to join the army and I want
to go to Vietnam and Cambodia and get
sort of a hook up with like a great hash
dealer and come back and be like a drug
dealer of note here in South Milwaukee
Wisconsin that was his dream when he was
17 loved the one people's brains work so
differently and they see they see their
goals are achieved in just the most
confusing convoluted breath it's like
did you want to make a three bank three
like you wanna and he gets it from our
dad my dad could it could have been the
richest guy in town he could have been
mr. Potter
but he go who was go go go get her moans
get out of here so what your dad yeah he
could but he he can't he needs it to be
hard so he's a Salesman and he said he
was like a bag miner bag man for the mob
in Milwaukee so you know the Milwaukee
mob so it wasn't a Corleone Soprano kind
of moment it was it was more of a Frank
Pulaski kind of moment and you know the
mom in Milwaukee is not and my dad he
was just he had a gambling problem
so he ended up being a bagman just
because he's like what you want to work
it off and he's like yeah I do I do want
to work about he one time he we had
$1,000 at his pocket and he let me hold
it and count it really and greatest dad
in the world sometimes my pop and other
times it's not great not great but so
but my so my brothers are torn to this
hole but my brother Russ he has said it
before he said you know what I do with
that because he hangs out with our dead
a lot he's like what I do is dad tells
me how he would do something and then he
tells me and then he goes and does it
differently because it's too easy that
way and I do it the way he told me to do
and then I make a hundred
and then dad has $7,000 oh my god he's
like well why don't you tell the rest of
us that and he said yeah whatever you
sit around with him and so what was the
moment I was just thinking about this
this morning when was the moment when
you realized your parents were human
pretty early I mean it was you know like
my mom died when I was seven and and so
and we never mentioned her again and the
theory was is that if you can't say
something nice don't say anything at all
and she died she was it was it was her
boyfriend flipped off split off they
were separated and I recorded the dark
forest with my dad by the way that I
have never aired because I was so mad at
him that he had just because my cuz his
dork dome my dad's dork to miss sales
yeah but when you say that everything
much like my husband's everything is a
game to him everything is a sale to my
dismay oh yeah including women including
going to the 7-eleven and buying a soda
absolutely can't turn it off
everything's a joke to me everything is
a joke to me and he cannot turn it off
so we are at Leon's getting frozen
custard in Milwaukee they are a dollar
fifty each
my father's like well what do you want
for this and the what the kid work in
the window is like they're a dollar
fifty each and he said well you don't
have like a senior discount or you know
I was just I got I got five dollars
right here for the three of us is that
something no no it isn't something dad
find another day I'm going to use that I
swear to god I'm going to steal that and
use that in life when I'm in a bar my
father is chock-full of great lines oh
that's so that's so [ __ ] great yeah
well so on the pod he's telling me about
how he met my stepmother and him and my
mother are separated and he's like so
he's like so it's a solid sorry
Nancy when I'm at the bar and it's 19
whatever and I'm like and so there's
this pause and I go dad I don't like the
Matt and I'm genuinely angry and I go I
don't like the math on that dad I don't
like the math on you with Nancy and he
goes well that's the math you know I
didn't tell my fault yes it is it's
specifically you're the two people
involved in that [ __ ] story yeah
you're the one who's all still with my
mother hitting on Nancy Kasia
so the math was the math was he was
still with my mother hitting and then he
goes well that's not my fault that's the
math you should have seen me in the 60s
with Yvonne and I was like dad I don't
want to see you in the 60s with Yvonne
you are familiar with the fact that I am
your daughter so your mom had six kids
yes and then and then she died and then
she is and this I met her at the end
right what's fascinating about you jack
is that there is still so much of you
you are the most open like like sweetest
liberal like but there's still a part of
you that is old school like there's
still a hint of old school in you it's
like it's like a cocktail and you're
like you're like is that is that is that
a lemon rind and you're like you could
taste it you're like yeah you never miss
it but like there's soap there's part of
you that's so open so honest so like
available and then there's also a part
of you that's like 1970s Milwaukee oh
yeah like Wisconsin very much it's there
is it's it makes such a beautiful person
because you are this person that things
like you know the hashtag yesallwomen
really [ __ ] matter to you yeah and
and and and but then there's still a
part of you that's like and so my mom
died took like an you're like barrel
through oh great a Barrett walk it off
well in that so I mean I tried for about
a year and a half to do this thing about
grief because my stepmother passed away
three years ago and it was very sad and
also very funny because this this
disaster okay so she dies July 25th
three years ago so uh I don't know
you'll remember it when I tell the story
so she dies I go and it was unexpected I
had lunch with her two weeks earlier
luckily my husband and I went back and
had lunch and and then and she was sick
she was you know she was always had sort
of hard health but it was unexpected
that she passed away and so it was very
sad and then so I go home for the
funeral I come back to LA I walk into
bar Lubitz there's a bunch of comics and
with all t comics and one of them I know
pretty well and he's like how's it going
I was like oh my mom and my stepmom
raised me from when I was eight till now
so she is my mother I will stuff I will
put her crazy against anybody's
biological mother because I hated her
and loved her as much as you love your
own mother yes so because she was my mom
and so I was like oh my mom died and I
was just at the funeral and he goes oh
I'm so sorry one of the other comics a
very young very very funny young man
said Oh was she at that Batman movie in
Aurora
four days after both events so so
inappropriate from absolutely every
goddamn angle and I couldn't stop
laughing hey he captain Asperger's no no
she was not at the Batman movie where
she was gunned down you it was so
inappropriate I laughed because Nancy
keishon would have laughed yeah cuz she
loved stand-up comedy she was if I get
my timing and I get a lot of things from
my dad
but I get my sense of humor from Nancy
keishon yeah who was smart and dark
hilarious that's the most that's the
thing I'm proudest about or the thing I
cherish the most and I and I is is the
fact that I'm in a an a subculture of
people who are allowed to say that to
each other because they know that you
think you can do that like that our
peers are the funniest people in the
world right and they and we get to we
get privileged enough to hear half burst
into tears and half laughs yes face yeah
and I literally said captain Asperger's
yeah that isn't great
what did so you you lost mama seven do
you know what member
your mom well my mom was was literally
my mom was 16 when she got pregnant with
my oldest brother and she was 26 when
she had me so she had children under the
age of 10 and my father is a Salesman on
purpose so that he does not have to be
there so what he did was he brought home
a ferret a lot of money
and he gave it all to her and then he
was like and about raised these kids I
gotta go and so kids that is so many
children that is 70 26 years old she's
still a young woman yes that's the thing
that's lost by the way lost all of her
teeth by the time she was thirty how you
say oh because she drank like a fish she
was the biggest alcoholic in though I
genuinely picture her right now in
heaven with a cigarette and a beer going
oh good you didn't need me it worked up
oh that's great I picked her totally in
heaven a heaven where there are no six
children under the age of 10 and I loved
her but she was a disaster and I don't
blame her for being a disaster because
how my oldest brothers are like no she
was great she cooked and cleaned and she
tried to do you know she genuinely tried
to do that June Cleaver Leave It to
Beaver thing probably for the first
three kids and then exhaustion and she
just won and when my dad left my dad
left in like 69 and I was four and he
moved out of town and he didn't give her
any child support because she just blew
it on booze so he gave it to my
grandmother his mother and all of my
older siblings would go and eat over at
her house but there was no food in our
house like my I remember my second
oldest brother he would feed me my
oldest brother was 14 and 15 and getting
laid and was the hottest guy in really
my second oldest brother is an old woman
and I love him dearly and he will cry at
the drop of a hat he is very emo but he
is also enormous Lee is one of the
nicest most sincere dudes in the world
and when he was 10 and 11 he would cook
for me and and we were like the Lord of
the Flies right I mean there was a lot
of infighting
I can't imagine six kids dad's gone moms
drinking and
Wisconsin in racing in the south in the
tiny factory town just like there's you
know part of it I and I can't help but
think it this way and I don't know if
it's but if part of it's very romantic
well I have I mean we've all relatively
we've kind of romanticized it to some
extent where you're just like I was five
years old hitchhiking didn't hurt his
family yeah and Gary Curtis and my
infilling Terry did their soda pop and
Ponyboy best I mean Terry would play
pool and bring money home to pay for
rent we lived in a in a three two and a
half bedroom apartment the six of us
with my mom so two brothers my two
brothers were in one room my mom was in
one room my brother Phil were was in the
pantry that had been turned into a
bedroom Darla and I shared a bed and I
wet the bed until I was eight and she's
still to this day sleeps on the edge of
the Nancy keishon cured me of the
wedding of the bed she was like every
day you don't wet the bed you get a star
you make it thirty days I get you a toy
and so it worked
took one month to Nancy Kate I mean Phil
Phil sells the story said you know Nate
mom died and the next day dad was back
and there was food in the kitchen and he
said we were sad about mom but there was
food in the kitchen
so we dried our tears with peanut butter
and jelly sandwiches it was I mean how
did your mom die she drove off a cliff I
heard and her boyfriend we're on a
motorcycle they flipped they were drunk
and they'd flipped off an overpass and
got run over by cars the worst he lived
Harold Harold lived and I used to do a
joke that nobody thought was funny
except for three people which was it was
a Harley Davidson so we were proud
could you imagine the neighbors if it
had been a Kawasaki anyway I mean that
was just devastated but he just I mean
cuz it removed we met him when he was
kid Phil used to talk about what he was
he was a good guy like he wanted mom to
marry Harold cuz Harold had a job at PE
and it like a factory job and he was a
good guy because you know Harley's are
expensive yeah but my mom liked
she genuinely was drunk all the time and
there was nothing by the time I met her
she was just a disaster of a human being
and I feel bad for her during your
pregnancy Oh totally my grandmother
would tell me my grandmother hated her
she thought that my grandmother that my
mom had ruined my father's life all by
herself
it was weird she was the only one who
talked about it you know those those
people don't exist anymore who will talk
like that like my grandmother passed my
grandmother my grandmother was not happy
that I was getting married to my wife
and was vocal about it oh those people
don't exist I mean I don't know if they
exist anymore but she was like well no
she's a lowland Scot she's from she's
from oh you're my grandmother's life
camp
we're from Georgia from a small town in
Georgia at the foothills of Appalachia
just a lowland Scot we can't marry those
Wow and I was like my dad no one told me
I loved my grandmother yeah and then my
dad finally said what my mom said my mom
brought it up is that um she would she
would that my wife is very adamant about
keeping my grandmother in the loop of my
daughter so she'd call her like maybe
once a week but maybe more than that
maybe twice a week call her and let her
talk to the girls and she really
included her in my daughter's lives and
up until when she passed and so my
grandmother loved my mom that's [ __ ]
day one well like she just started she's
my friend first what's funny is that my
sister is gay and has always been gay
and is very gay and doesn't care and and
my whole family is very much like that
we're we're just like yeah this is what
I do if you don't like it you should
probably not like me I gotta go and but
my sister I got one speed I that but
that is that's so fascinating because I
say that to people I go no I go like
what was I saying as you said it today
Oh someone said someone had a [ __ ]
note to me they wanted to like say
something that I had said that it hurt
their feelings and I said I've said very
candidly
hey listen unless you [ __ ] me or pay me
I don't care we have to say yeah
like those two people you pay me or [ __ ]
me and I'll listen to you I'll listen to
you I'll try to change but other than
you're not my swing son like my radius
honey I'm sorry whatever I said I drink
a lot sometimes I say some things that
are inappropriate and but just ignore me
yeah so but it's so funny because my
mother my stepmother was like Darlie you
can't tell grandma that you're gay it'll
kill her and our grandmother is Armenian
and Daryl was like so she lived through
the Armenian Genocide but me being gay
that's gonna me liking wanting to date
women that's gonna she was marched
through Lebanon and Syria for months
some guy who really liked camels no
woman on woman love that's gonna really
that's gonna devastate her I thought I
was thinking about this today I was like
this is a it's neat to know that like Oh
thinking of like one of our like a
friend of ours if his son was gay and he
came about and honestly he'd grow up in
a place where he could honestly probably
say it was dad I like I think I like
boys better than girls and any of my
friends would all be like that's totally
fun and my so okay yeah and I was
thinking I was like that's really neat
that that exists now it's yeah it is
good that that that people can hear it
and not be super cuz I remember when
Darla came out and I remember when my
friend when my friend Mary Skinner came
out if you ever submit Mary Skinner
you'd be like oh you did not know that
Mary Skinner was gay because I have the
worst gaydar I thought I was gay for a
little while that's how bad she was gay
right and then I made out with a couple
of women and I was like no this is not
what I'm looking for and so my wife's
mom thought she was gay
Oh Nancy thought I was gay too but I was
but I was like no and my as my husband
it was very funny because he was like
you're the worst
you're the most into [ __ ] woman to be
gay and I was like did you just say [ __ ]
that's a lot I scream for a game my
husband's family his entire family is
from Mississippi like both sides of his
family but he was raised in like some
weird little Oroville California was
raised in a little
golde town outside everyone thinks
everyone thinks Mississippi's so
different and so like such a different
place but you go there you know it's
just very similar to North Florida
Alabama it's you can't even they get
cable you guys it's all working out it
is the public school system is terrible
but I will say this cuz I'm doing this
thing about how I love guns but I don't
know anything about them
and mines nothing right which should
terrify and every time I say I was like
they make a big noise and the rip in the
paper and my in-laws they're just steam
comes out of there and they're because
the public school system may suck in
Mississippi but gun safety everyone
knows that's they they got common sense
down as far as guns and stuff if they
shoot you they meant to in Wisconsin
people are constantly accidentally
shooting each other they shoot you they
meant to and in in Miss I'm gonna say
Mississippi and I don't know if just in
the South if they shoot you they're
gonna kill you also like that is the
other thing my wife done and she says
she is and he has no interest his dad
was a like they lived in Arkansas till
he passed away about three years ago as
well but he had all these guns and his
wife his current wife his widow was like
aunt Andy do you want any of these guns
and and he's like well I don't need them
I'm good I don't like yes [ __ ] all of
them well because the thing is is I I
gave me a bow and Andy gave me I'm doing
this bit now and I this is how I talk I
talk about comedy this is but so he gave
me what I call a Hunger Games kit for
Christmas the greatest gift in the world
I got moccasins which I've never had but
I've always wanted yeah I got a bow and
arrow
a real bow and arrow with a quiver that
was a prop from Xena you see yeah what's
a real quiver if it's a prop from Xena
it's a real quiver it's a leather quiver
and it's got arrows in it and it's a
real bow and then and then my
mother-in-law gave me a knife so I got
Hunger Games kit and I put it all on
right when I got it and I was heading
out the door bow in hand and Andy says
to me where are you going and I said
Erin's and he was like no please no and
it was a reveal of why people want to
openly carry the damn guns and it's cuz
it's cool it's super cool fun as [ __ ]
and Andy goes
only cool to you making everyone else
uncomfortable and it's a huge reveal hey
gun owners you're safe at the Denny's we
don't need our weapons at the Denny's
and I have three friends who collect
swords who totally want to wear their
swords out but even gun people would
make fun of us oh I did to my to my
buddies are are like gun carrying guys
yeah conceal and carry but think about a
derringer on your forearm oh I don't
have a gun oh wait a minute yes I do I
totally get it
my buddy cow had it that comes in two
Ybor you've done cow it I'm sure in
Tampa I've done the Improv with Maria
and it's like a three story Improv
Theater you're like that's half full
that's unfortunate for all of us it's uh
it's a bit too big [ __ ] it's a big [ __ ]
ow head does a radio show down there
he's got he has his he has his [ __ ]
weapon on him and we whenever we go to
hang out he always wants to go to this
shooters world I think it's called and
they arrange yeah I'm obsessed I love
talking about obsession and I'm obsessed
with knives I don't have any money so
yeah bag full of knives have a bag full
of knives thankfully cool knives you
guys these are I'm obsessed with knives
so I have like knives everywhere let me
see the bag we just said I'll browse
while you talk about your knife
collection oh but those are just some
those are traveling knives those are
more functioning those nail clipper
here's a scissors you just like pointy
things man you can tell oh my god
thunder [ __ ]
that's hilarious you don't have I got
I've gotten so many of these confiscated
by TSA uh a beautiful one I one of my
favorite knife companies is Spyderco
yeah and yeah it's a great knife company
this great Swiss Army knives are
underrated I bought him from me my wife
and my daughters and got our names
engraved in them and when I was in
Switzerland but Spyderco makes a great
knife that's just a Leatherman for me
it's like sitting in the hotel room on a
Sunday mumbling just and just like
cleaning my toenails I want a night for
that oh do you but like these spider
codes that I was in I was in Africa and
I had a really great night Africa where
did you go to that South African comedy
festival no I did I was doing
the South African comedy festivals
really fun I really love it I would love
it you would I went to Djibouti wants to
yes Djibouti has her own joke but I went
to perform for the troops and in in
northern Africa which is still super
cool I was like I've been to Africa but
I would love to go to anywhere in Africa
Tanzania Zanzibar South Africa Durban
jobber it's nice to meet people with
t-shirts on of the team that didn't win
from the south from the Superbowl I just
love I genuinely love travelling to
where no places cuz places that you
don't get to travel to that like and II
got offered to judge of a video game
contest in Iran and he had to turn it
down cuz he had other work but I mean he
was like should I even go and I was like
when was the next time you were thinking
about getting a free trip to Iran yeah
Iran Iran no I said Iran Iran 1980 like
the Shah still in church by our members
that's one bomb bomb bomb bomb bomb Iran
keep writing Q 105 guys Shannon and
Cleveland wheeler and the weasel I was I
was I'm gonna go through my subtle
obsessions okay do it I love to knives
gloves like I loves gloves
I love gloves weird like I like good
gloves very soft hands no but nobody I
don't but it like these are actually
randomly enough these are a pair of my
favorite gloves they're trichome Otis
Tucker's and they're just motorcycle
gloves okay like I do a lot of outdoor
stuff okay for the Travel Channel so
your was the glove so I have a good set
of belay gloves I've got a pair of
fingerless play gloves
I've got motorcycle gloves I've got
horseback riding gloves like I've got
I've got I've got scuba diving gloves
I've got I've got outdoor I've got ski
gloves I've got so many gloves
yeah like my wife little goes crazy
knives
like I get knives wherever I go I didn't
remind me of the trip how you play
mumbly peg what's that
mumbly plague peg mumbly peg oh it's the
game where you throw the knife on the
ground and and you it's sort of like
horse but with knives no oh my god
Google mumbly peg mumbly peg it is yeah
somebody memo about mumbly peg yeah yeah
that's great I'm obsessed with
podcasting oh yeah
I'm sitting not making them right has
anyone listening this can tell right
I've been well I've been very I've been
very slack lately but you smite better
men on the road and I don't not
comfortable doing solo podcasts so what
I'm gonna do now is I'm gonna release
one with a guest
every week on Tuesday and then one with
a solo one with me just talking on
Thursday just just to kind of help build
I do it all myself that's why I when I'm
working I get very backlog because I'm
I'm working for travel doing this show
birthing guy oh no I'm very like just
like I said I asked you that control for
and I go very big control freak and I go
hey if you want me to put this and I'll
take it out so I look at it no one's
ever gonna [ __ ] do that and then one
day you I put something in it you're not
comfortable sharing and you get mad at
me not the editor and so I'm very well
what I did what I here's what I do
because I've been doing it the nine
years this month the pod and then I take
notes with timecode and cuz I do while
you're doing it while I'm doing it
because I do a log I do a clip that I
put out the day before like this week's
episode is with Paul Gilmartin about
woodworking love Paul Kilmartin
and he's a woodworking dork and and so
which I asked him if he doesn't he
whittled and he does not he does not do
any whittling he said that he's like you
know people who Whittle it's always a
shitty horse and I said except for the
one guy who could totally wouldn't do it
totally cool horse he's like I have
never met that guy almost got into
whittling almost gone the whittling
because it needed needed knives a knife
set in from whittling I was in I was in
once I was in Colorado and there was a
indoor skydiving place that we were
going share and right next door was a
big art shop and I walked in because I
love art and I'm walking around and all
the sudden I'm like I love art I love
making art like I like messing around
right and so I saw a whittling kit
knowing I'm getting a [ __ ] with
Lincoln
I bought a watercolor kit and have never
touched it I opened it sadly have not
gotten with it we do what we'll do as me
and my daughters will get oil canvas and
oil paints and we'll take one Georgia
O'Keeffe painting and we'll all do our
version of that oh that's neat
yeah we got we've done we've done it
twice that's not like we do it all the
time but but you've done it a couple
it's done yeah in Italy but yeah but and
then my daughter's very artistic I
bought them both I went to a art shop
and I bought them art journals and great
pen sets and I said you know draw
pictures of things you do so it's poem
for my daughter and veil and she started
doing drawing her days my other one just
draws and she'll do representations of
what she remembers going on that morning
okay today it was a picture of ila
Georgia drew it was picture of ila
refusing to eat her breakfast and then
Georgia commenting on it like almost
like a comic book one of the reasons I
like doing that that uh the Mel because
you get oh you get the 40 bucks I go
over and I just buy comic books for
Georgia excellent [ __ ] how old is she
11 11 she might enjoy a comic book
called runaways really yeah I think it
was Joss Whedon who dude open or it
might have been Bryan Kavon actually
really yeah runways it's essentially the
logline of it is every kid thinks that
their parents are super villains these
kids are their parents are super
villains oh shut up yeah it is an 11s
perfect oh I'll get it yeah you're
[ __ ] amazing
it turns out I don't have I just spent a
lot of time reading anyway so but yeah
it you buy dad paints by the way and
yeah and he sent me a couple of his
paintings and uh he's they're good
they're there he actually does it's very
realism he doesn't curl as always I'm
forget I'm gonna go forget about I guess
we can listen to this the [ __ ] am i
writing it down for right well yeah
because what I do is yeah so I so I
released like a four-minute clip with a
with a slug like like a picture of the
person who's on the pod and a tiny
little picture of whatever they're
Dorking out about and then and then the
sort of the logo of the show the dark
forest what is one of the what if you
could say top five episodes
you've done that people would go right
now download and then fall in love with
your podcast because of Greg Proops the
history of baseball personality baseball
one is amazing all Greg Proops episodes
are amazing Patton Oswalt's wife
Michelle McNamara yeah does this thing
called true crime diary and she loves
serial killers it was one of the first
she's done three or four episodes and
they're amazing
there's great episodes like the one
about surfing that I just did with Marie
valeriano and Monte Franklin was great
and the Marie on this week I think oh
nice yeah and then but there's they're
like Aisha Tyler talking about video
games was amazing the Maria Bamford
episodes are all great the O diva Zappa
Frank Zappa's youngest daughter yeah did
knitting that was fantastic because when
you think of a ZAPPIN itting yeah
because I was like so knitting dorks are
super like anal right like you if you
drop a stitch you got to undo because I
don't knit but you got to undo and redo
but not diva Zappa divas that was like I
always think if I drop a stitch that
that that bump was meant to be they're
talking about beading totally OCD it's
like no I undo and redo and undo and
redo so I mean so I'm like I'm she beat
and beats beats beating she makes hating
eating I was like what Janeane Garofalo
beats by the way I'll tell you something
rage alright [ __ ] I've always had the
biggest crush on Janeane Garofalo
everyone said you know what I one time I
remember just being hammered hanging out
with a buddy of mine named Spencer
Dobson and him almost you know Spencer
Dobson yes blond hair tall yeah Spencer
and he was friends with KP yeah yeah
yeah very funny guy though Spencer
[ __ ] Dobson you know Spencer I I
don't I haven't talked to him in forever
but Spencer Dobson wasn't worked on my
show the ex show there you go yeah
that's it and so but he I remember just
both of us just hammered and cat dog or
whatever the cat's I don't know some
movie came out about cats and dogs yeah
we're quite as poultry with you place
the pretty one and and
he's like half of the bag and it goes
Janeane Garofalo is nobody's Ugly
Duckling not it not happening and I was
like I agree I don't know what like like
Amy Schumer yes like somebody said Amy
Schumer is God I stopped talking about
how she's not good-looking she's the
hottest thing in the world man
yeah and I'm like calm down I get it you
think she's pretty and so yeah but yeah
there's there's episodes of I mean if
you go actually there's every year I
have fan favorites people vote on their
favorite episodes Joseph scrimshaw did a
defense of the the Star Wars prequels
that nobody should not listen to because
first of all how can you defend the Star
Wars prequels and Joseph scrimshaw does
a beautiful job
that's [ __ ] by the way I thought he
would totally talk about carving handles
of knives oh there he goes
yeah yeah I did scrimshaw one time
scrimshaw
and there's I mean but the the one of
the great things about the dark force is
that there's there's sort of famousy
people on it like Jim Gaffigan talking
about news personalities yeah and and
then I don't know I Greg Fitzsimmons
talked about rage and he's an
interesting guy when he talks about that
stuff zuly McCullough has over a hundred
pairs of tennis shoes sneaker dork oh
that that's very popular that's a thing
that is real like there are people there
are people that that grown men who are
obsessed with sneakers Sulu McCullough
is obsessed with his Instagram is
entirely just pictures of his sneakers
Mike Mike a little cousin David is
obsessed with sneakers and yeah just
Google some non-stop I was obsessed I
went through a massive obsession with
bullmastiffs before we got Priscilla all
I do is Google bullmastiffs I could tell
you more about bullmastiffs and you'd
ever need to know she's a very sweet dog
very sweet she's been she's been a
little bit of a headache in that she's
had a lot of surgeries because she was
pure bred and so they're very slow
breeding and if you ever thinking about
buying a purebred dog don't and if you
do get let pet insurance that's my
insurance it's a I do a lot of jokes
about pets in but pet insurance joke
that never that nobody wants to hear is
that if you have a baby
you should also buy a dog yeah that same
year and get life insurance on that dog
and then 16 years later leave the gate
open and then you could pay for your
daughter's college and then everyone
looked at me like I was the [ __ ] and
they were of course correct because I
genuine iguana reptile obsession
aggressively in college aggressively
like I had a savannah Monitor I didn't
I'm on a ride iguana we had a ball
python Wow like the only reason we have
an iguana is because the entire Ashcraft
Foley family all of Andy's relatives
they never ever buy animals they never
get animals they always someone hands
them a [ __ ] animal and like literally
his dad had a horse and these beagles
that would hunt deer and he was a and
but he didn't any trained bird dogs so
he didn't trained beagles he trained
bird dogs and so he had bird dogs like
English whatever but his mom's have all
of these dogs and cats and so Andy has
an iguana because a guy came to
PlayStation when he was working at
Playstation and had just bought three
iguanas iguanas grow to be almost
[ __ ] massive I never got the real fun
out of mine it never got big as they was
Woodbury I think well no he did die yeah
very hilarious which is awesome which is
it's hard to keep them alive I'm gonna
find that clip if I have it I'm gonna
find that clip and post it of me talking
about the time I tried to cremate my
iguana because he died not it and I
thought it would be more tasteful to
cremate him it just turned into a
[ __ ] nightmare
did you put cream did you try to cremate
him yourself I'm not even gonna try to
telex I'll start laughing hysterically
but like but yeah iguanas monitors and
snakes then there was a well we ride
back to Tallahassee every there was to
be this big reptile farm and on our way
you had to take a little bit of a detour
and I got stopped there every time and
I'd spend at least an hour just looking
at reptiles and usually picking one up
but
what are you looking for your wanna yeah
can I tell you what I really want to do
I want to have like an animal kingdom
back here what I'd like to do is live
you ever do Wilmington the dead crow
this the the dead crow comedy club in
Wilmington North Carolina
wanna read iguana yeah Tiberius Drac us
he's named after a Roman a Roman general
named Tiberius Gracchus named Tiberius
yes and Andy got him and he was little
and then but now he's 21 years old and
they lived to be about 30 though five
years ago and he said they live to be
about 25 so as we go yeah but I can't
get a dog because I'm on the road too
much like you have on the road somebody
talking my wife just takes care of it
well that's Andy was like I have always
had a dog I don't want a dog right now
it's too much work it's a lot of work
it's a lot less a lot more work than an
iguana
yeah the iguana you can actually leave
it in wanna cuz they need to be fed I'm
obsessed with pets I what I want is I
want iguana what I'd like what I'd mean
dead serious if I could run like a
little bit of like a kingdom back here I
would like I would like a big nice
McCall like Cleveland bird like a bird
that but I would I wish I had like what
I really like is in is like an owl like
an like an owl bear that's a D&D
reference guru anyway so you would like
an owl I was like an owl I like a
Savannah cat like one of the one of the
first generations there cats are like 40
pounds they get to be like this big like
Bobcat it's almost like a bobcat it's
more like they domesticated their
domesticated okay they're illegal in
some places okay I would like another
bull mastiff I'd like an iguana and then
that would kind of round out my backyard
well and and and obviously I decided I
wanted tortoise I almost bought my
daughter of [ __ ] Phoenix fennec fox
for a birthday because I was like it's
like that moment where you realize like
wait I'm a grown-up no one gets to tell
me what to do you could do whatever you
are not rich but I got some money like I
could buy a [ __ ] fennec fox you have
a disposable income it's I had a lego
dork on the other day it was Tommy Ryman
great comic yeah
he he said you know I was at the store
and there was like I think it was like a
$300 Lego kit to make a bowl any
infection or something and he was like I
actually could afford that he's like not
every week but like once a year I could
buy a $300 and so he bought a ginormous
like millennium I was like was it a
life-sized could you sit in it britta
wash as a joke like you know you can buy
a birthday cake for yourself any day you
want to George because ila my youngest
obsessed with finding foxes I wanted
George and I go George hey let's get you
I love fennec fox for her birthday and
George is like are you out of your mind
wild animal into this house yeah but
yeah Jackie I really appreciate you
doing this so it went by so fast thank
you so it was an hour 45 so it was
fantastic I could take it literally I
think we could let's keep talking but
let's nobody has to sit through it yeah
let's let's I please let me do dork for
us I'd love to I'll find my specific
obsession that I could talk at nauseam
about right and then whoa I think you're
gonna be a little bit of plug-and-play
my friend yeah we will start talking and
then the hour cuz I only do an hour
yeah I usually do I try to keep it at
like below two hours but I've gone
through I've got five yeah that's I I
get tired I get I just had a wrestling
dork on and I was like and we're done
Mike Schmidt and Andi Peters too did an
hour 45 they wouldn't stop talking and
finally I just said I'm turning it off
you guys you guys could talk about this
for till you grow old but we're I'm done
listening to it podcast or forest dark
forest calm the dark forest gump and the
only pet ancestry.com I bought it
because it made me laugh because don't
you wanna know if your cat came over on
the Mayflower come my pet ancestry doc
don't you wander off your dogs I'll join
the DAR my wife's a redneck her parents
met on ancestry mingle
so yeah check her out and you're the
best thank you so much
this episode was brought to you by the
machine
you